joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
is Peter King how are you Peter I'm
doing well how about you did I get that
right I mean you Tom basically told you
Saturday night what he Instagram down
today right pretty much you know I think
so I haven't seen it somebody somebody I
was on another show a while ago and they
they told me hey Brady says he's coming
back and I I said yeah yeah well let me
let me read it to you because let me
read it to you when you meet another
show you probably mean a lesser show but
I understand what you're saying Peter he
wrote at the end of his Instagram
posting you don't always win you can
however learn from that failure pick
yourself up with great enthusiasm and
place yourself in the arena and that's
right where you will find me because I
know I still have more to prove and he
left it at that that's what he said yeah
he said to me the other night I know I
can still play at a championship level
Ricks Tom Brady wants to play football
again there's very little doubt that
unless 32 teams say we don't want Tom
Brady there's very little doubt he will
play football next year and I think
there's a good chance I'm not saying
it's better than 5050 I just think it's
a good chance that he will play for a
team other than the Patriots well then
let's go into that why would that happen
because we did see with our own two eyes
obviously the Brady that won Super Bowls
in the in the early office is not the
Brady that we're seeing now but we're
also seeing some throws like a couple
throws he made to Edelman on the fourth
quarter that game that had as much zip
on it as anybody else that would throw
it to Edelman and there's nobody else
this year into the end exactly and and
so and the cupboards bare behind him
right now as we know so why wouldn't
Brady be back in New England Peter well
because if you look at what would have
to happen this is just my opinion
that's how Brady didn't tell me well
they have to do this shirt this has to
happen for me to be back this is totally
my inference my reading of the teal
okay in my opinion I don't think Tom
Brady wants to go anywhere that he
doesn't have a good chance to win and
rich do you remember do you remember
this year in Buffalo after the Patriots
beat Buffalo but look crappy doing so
yes and afterwards Tom Brady was as
unhappy upset whatever word you would
use at a press conference after a game
as he's been it one of the lowest he's
ever been after a football game okay and
they just won on the road in Buffalo the
best team in their division other than
them
and so everybody simple jeez why that it
why is that this is again I am just
reading tea leaves here okay hmm because
Tom Brady is a very close to the vest
guy all right but my feeling at that
time and my feeling over the weekend was
and I'll tell you why I felt this way
over the weekend my feeling at the time
is that Tom Brady had to know that with
this cast that we have right now we
can't win a Super Bowl we can't win a
championship they have not given us
enough to win and Bill Belichick has
done a marvelous job over the years in
figuring out when to let guys go and who
to sign and all that stuff this was not
Bill Belichick finest architectural hour
he can tell you that much anybody who
watched the Patriots could see that and
you fast forward to after this game and
Tom Brady basically as I wrote in my
column this week after leaving him ten
twelve minutes however long I had with
him my overriding thought was what
happened tonight did not surprise Tom
Brady one bit mm-hmm and you know it
doesn't matter what the seed was where
they were hey look rich
after how after Halloween this year the
Miami Dolphins were five and four in the
Patriots were four and five so you know
what has happened is should not be a
shock to anybody nor
going into the future you ask why
wouldn't he go back to New England I
think he would be happy to go back to
New England if there was a team that had
a couple of big-time wide receivers with
all due respect to Julian Edelman this
year you know he was good he only caught
a hundred balls in my opinion because
Brady had nobody else let's put it let's
put it in a real time than Peter because
you know the way this works is that the
new league is gonna hit and and if he's
a if he's a free agent
that then all bets could be off it it
would actually potentially harm New
England's cap should he be Carter traded
and buy by the new league year
Brady won't know unless it's it's Kraft
and Belichick telling him in a meeting
that they have somewhere off campus on
campus wherever but trust us we'll get
you the receivers you need you don't
have that question that you say would be
paramount from having answered but
listen if if Belichick and Kraft put
them in a room in you know you know
whatever if they sat together somewhere
yep in the next seven weeks which is
going to happen and Belichick looked
them in the eye and said I'm going to
get two receivers and we will if we
don't get a really good one in free
agency our top our top pick is going to
be a tight end
Madhvi look again I am he talked like I
know what's going on he said I know
nobody does Tom Brady wants to have a
chance and then watching him this year
yep I just don't think he he felt with
those weapons he had a chance well
nobody also knows what's going through
we can assume what we know what's going
through Bob crafts head which is like
there's no way I'm gonna let Tom Brady
wear somebody else's uniform and then
there's the the question of Bill
Belichick do you think there's any
chance they want him to wear another
team's uniform but right what Bob Kraft
said to me okay is that I hope and pray
that number one Tom Brady's back with
knowing
or number two he retires as a patriot
well that's not what Tom Brady hopes for
it and the fact that Tom Brady has his
freedom uh Tom Brady's playing football
so he might do one of the two things
that Bob Kraft hopes and prays for but
he's not going to do the second one is
not an option that is unless nobody
wants them which I think somebody will
want him to please I think that's for
sure what are the odds that Belichick in
a meeting with Kraft looks at him and
says I told you Jimmy Garoppolo was our
guy and now we're in this situation now
let's just rip the band-aid off let's go
I've got this plan draft this person
this free agent however I think that's a
look Bill Belichick a quarter-century go
enraged the people of Cleveland by
benching Bernie Kosar for Todd Phil Cox
and 18 years ago our 19 years ago
whatever it was he kept the highest-paid
football player in the NFL drew bledsoe
on the bench when he was healthy enough
to play and he continued to start Tom
Brady and I would bet a lot of money
that that wasn't a popular decision in
the owners office at that time but Bill
Belichick it charlie weis was on my
podcast this week okay and obviously
charlie weis coached on for five years
on that first Patriots staff when
Belichick got the job in 2000 and he
told me that knowing Bill the way he did
he feels that the Devin McCourty
decision and the Devin and the loyalty
to Devin McCourty would be just as deep
as the loyalty and the decision on Tom
Brady him you know it's tough a decision
and he's gonna do what he I give
Belichick a ton of credit for only
thinking about one thing and that is the
team the team the team right he's a Bo
Schembechler guy and it's ironic
obviously that that Brady's a Michigan
guy too because you know that is the way
that Bill Bell
chick is gonna go forward and if he
feels that Tom Brady is this guy for the
next two years I think he's going to try
hard to make it happen but if he has
some doubt about that either because of
the finances of it or whatever I will
not be at all surprised to see him go
hard after then don't laugh at this say
an Andy Dalton or a teddy bridgewater to
try to make them either a short-term
bridge - Jared Stidham or to somebody
else who they draft or to just get in
the job Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show and obviously we've got weeks
to see how this all plays out you know I
know we could sit here and talk McCarthy
and we will for a split second but what
in the world was going on in Dallas last
week with Garrett and the team I mean
what that was the most bizarre post
season week between team and obvious
firing for head coach I've ever seen
Peter do we know right I just think it
was the Dallas Cowboys showing some
incredible loyalty to somebody who as a
as an organization they love as much as
any player / coach as Jerry Jones has
had in his whatever in his 30 years in
Dallas and I know that sounds funny but
it isn't just Jason Garrett it is Jim
Garrett the former scout and the former
college football coach Jason Garrett's
father but Jim Garrett was also a
beloved member of the organization and
in some ways Jerry Jones I believe
almost feels like a surrogate dad after
the death of of Jim Garrett he loves uh
you know he really loves Jason Garrett
and I think he felt I'm going to give
him every opportunity let's just see
what happens and then when we find
somebody we love if we do then and only
then are we gonna let Jason Garrett go I
I just think it was trying to show as
much respect as they could so they they
were spending time last week consider
bringing him back or I don't think I
don't think that even though they say
that now I don't think that was a
serious consideration but who knows
maybe it's a one in a hundred so why let
him go until we have to that's that's my
only view of how why this happened but I
think Jerry knew just from his paying
customer they did not want Jason Garrett
back and Jerry was was borderline
positive he wasn't going to bring him
back he just wanted to try to treat him
with as much respect as he could which
is I guess then have McCarthy over to
the house well he's still under contract
I mean that sounds like something out of
The Bachelor we're just missing a
windmill here Peter you know I mean so
all said and done what how different is
the McCarthy that Dallas is getting than
the one that Green Bay fired after
losing to Arizona a couple of reasons
you know judging by the day and a half I
spent with them a couple of weeks ago in
Green Bay I think he's gonna have a
different approach to analytics
I mean rich this is a guy who showed me
a slide on his deck hmm which he has
ready to show NFL teams and so I'm
assuming that he showed this to David
Tepper and Jerry Jones he had a slide on
his deck that showed a 14-member
analytics slash technology slash video
Department and he was going to devote
fourteen people now would you think that
that is the way that that Jerry that
that Mike McCarthy would end up treating
analytics in my opinion I would never
have thought that he would have done
that so to me I kind of look at this now
and say this is a real logical way that
Mike McCarthy
modernized his approach to football and
in my opinion who's that adapt or die
mentality
that I believe he had helped him get the
Dallas Cowboys job about that couple
more minutes left with Peter King here
the chicken egg with Matt with Matt rule
and Joe judge
did the giant state judges our guy and
and then rule goes to Carolina or does
he go to the Giants and say I got
something from Carolina make sure I
don't get on the plane as Ian Rapoport
said how do those two hirings I would I
trust me and in that regard because I
don't know the answer to that question
yet and I just believe that the New York
Giants Navas others would have given
would have given 72 million over seven
years or 62 million over seven years to
a guy who'd come out of college football
and listen with all due respect in that
rule because I think he is an excellent
NFL can coaching candidate to give this
guy you know the first time NFL coach
the richest contract ever for a coach
the longest contract ever for a
first-time coach in the NFL knowing that
of the nine coaches this century who
have come from college football without
significant pro experience so I don't
tell Pete Carroll or Bill O'Brien in
there has had has won a playoff game and
that's that's Jim Harbaugh should know
all that at the time I I just find it
incredible that the Carolina Panthers
did that I just don't think there's any
way the New York Giants would have
agreed to that and who was Joe judge I
mean you know I knew rich I've never
talked to him in my life I've never met
him he's one of those Patriots
assistants who until there comes a time
or until you get him on media night at
the Super Bowl there is no way you're
ever really going to know him if you're
in a position like I am and and so I
think the beat guys probably knew him a
little bit but I
really don't know anything about him
other than you know his resume which is
that he worked for Nick Saban for a year
or two and now his work for Bill for a
while and clearly he's got a very good
pedigree but I find it very odd that the
New York Giants did not finish their
interviews knowing that there was nobody
else out there who wanted Joe judge so I
don't know those are questions I think
that remain to be answered
last one for you what are the Browns do
here they're the only ones left so you
know I don't know if you saw Joe
Thomas's Twitter thread yesterday saying
that he likes the position the Browns
are in because if anybody wants to be a
head coach now and leave their team they
know that this is the moment that they
potentially could be the hottest
candidate yeah and there's only one team
left what do you make of the Browns in
their leverage and what they're gonna do
here you know if I were them I'd be very
very patient I'd interview Josh
McDaniels I finished the round of
interviews then sit back take a deep
breath and say okay what do we have here
there's no need for them to rush into it
it is vastly overrated oh my god we got
to get a coach now so we can make sure
that we get we get the assistance that
we want how did that turn out for Frank
Reich getting hired on February 11 even
though two of the assistants were
hand-picked furnish I McDaniels and both
of them turned out to be good I get that
but the vast majority of coaches that he
hired were you know work done after the
Super Bowl so that's that's an overrated
deal to make sure you get your guys in
place if I were them personally I would
look very hard at Eric the enemy josh
mcdaniels and robert salla and i know
they're interviewing all of them but all
three of those guys should be head
coaches in the NFL all of them and now
they're going to have their choice of
any one of them and maybe there's some
other little under the radar stars they
love now but Joe is right there is no
hurry to do this and if I were them I
take their good sweet time Peter thanks
for your time greatly appreciated
football morning in America every single
Monday the Peter King podcast I was on
it last week enjoyed the experience you
should check it out thanks for the call
Peter
hey all the best fruits take care right
back at you Peter King at Peter
underscore King on Twitter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app